[Music]
Dude
[Music]
tell me where in the world is Michael
Strahan
he's not back yet so
I'm gonna play take him back seriously
[Music]
this is the stupidest thing ever
so is this it now is Pepsi just gonna be
our bumper guy yeah it's it's my let me
tell you something you know how many
people eat Bessie I just put it on
Twitter do you know how many people
message the account asking
I need the coma one please send me the
Como one
I want the con one so
bestie posted it on Twitter what tell
them about the gym
the what
didn't you say that you were at the gym
oh okay so I'm actually this is
hilarious you're gonna love it so I'm at
the gym and um our buddy who listens to
the show that you know you've met him so
anyway I walk in and the first thing he
says yesterday the first thing the very
first thing goes
good bread
loudly like across the gym I'm like [ __ ]
he goes he goes that [ __ ] hormone
thing was one of the funniest things you
guys did that ending was the stupidest
funniest thing ever
go [ __ ] bread
so
um
do you know what today is
it's Michael Strahan's birthday
and now can we can we first before we
get into this happy birthday Michael
happy birthday
so he's turning 51. they hit 51 years
old he looks amazing let's be realistic
Jesus Christ I can still kill you he's
51 but here's and by the way I was
listening to I can't we can't play it on
the triggers the NFL owns it but NFL has
miked up but when they used to Mike the
players I used to love that show oh my
God that was not as um we watched it
that was the first time he and me and
Royce ever learned to like Jay Cutler
yes we never liked Jacob until his mic'd
up us so we're like I don't know Jay
Cutler seems like a fun teammate he just
hangs out
okay anyway so I the fifth they did
something for his 51st birthday but it's
not online yet but what I figured I'd do
is
I have his 50th birthday so we're still
we're gonna celebrate his birthday I
thought you would love this because the
amount of stars that go out oh here we
go
Lionel Richie here Michael happy
birthday my daughter's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] hot though it was Nicole well yeah
Nicole Richie was hot the hotter of that
all those little socialite ones yeah
more than Paris you think okay and we
can't get enough of Strahan y'all
celebrating the big 5-0 a few days early
yeah it's a it's a birthday week yes it
should be I'll take it I know when it's
a milestone birthday I noticed
Stephanopoulos in the show for my
birthday again this year that's three
years in a row
Oh that's oh my god notice he's not
there he's not yeah no what what where's
George at what your I call me on like my
birthday I told we're gonna have cake
I've made sure to get his favorite
you like it's like that's the whole
dynamic is that he actually likes George
oh no I believe that to him 100
guy that doesn't even pick up on any of
the passive aggression she loves him he
respect he respects him we should be you
know what it is he [ __ ] knows shows
and Jordan and [ __ ] Michael's still
gonna save him a piece of cake of course
hey George I save you a piece of cake
it's in the break room for you because I
figured with red velvet I know you like
red I save you corner piece I'll save
you a corner piece he goes and just
throws it in the garbage spitefully
piece of [ __ ] and then in the afternoon
he pulls it out and he takes a couple
bites puts it back I still can't believe
this [ __ ] is 50 years old 51.
well no this is the old one I know but
still but like he looks exactly right
dude he's not here dude do you know what
it's like to be a former again he was a
defensive player and he was one of them
people that would just try one of the
best it ever did but let's be honest and
he trucked people his whole career and
like do you know what it's like to get
out of that career and not be first of
all a CTE riddled [ __ ] and then
actually not also not physically be all
[ __ ] up like that guy's a miracle in
the NFL because he played in the NFL
when when you were allowed to hit people
yeah when they were [ __ ] you were
allowed to hit people yeah he was down
but I just had all the attention but I
mean it's a milestone 50 of the locals
chat saying happy birthday Michael
Strahan happy birthday Master here for a
lot of people 50 the new 30. how about
that brother it is for you you
[ __ ] I know for me 30s the new 50
you piece of [ __ ]
we've lived nothing near the same
lifestyle sir okay for me 40s the new
60.
my left shoulder hurts for no reason now
for no reason agree with that Michael
knows how to oh there he is I was
kidding there he is I don't want your
[ __ ] cake though I'm like I don't
[ __ ] cake don't you know you piece of
[ __ ] you know makito I told you I'm a
keto meanwhile Strahan can eat like half
a cake yeah he's fine yeah every morning
you know how much energy brings this
show he wanted to show everybody some of
her favorite Michael moments
[Music]
I would be uncomfortable doing this
though being around that many Asia at
the same time I agree yeah that too is
that boys that sing that's boys that
sing yes Frozen is that you Frozen is
that you Frozen is that you froze it is
okay why are they some of them throwing
up Roman salutes what is that about whoa
boys look I don't know if anybody
explains you remember the side Japan was
on listen Jin Yang this is America okay
we don't enjoy all the same freedoms you
do in China
good reference
he is Michael Strahan all right first
off I know you we can make fun of him
right we can make fun of him for like
being gay or whatever
but
to be that big
at 50 and play football and still have
the flexibility to put your leg that
high is honestly super impressive well I
do hot yoga like twice a week of course
my wife makes me do it it's like one of
those things thanks Michael I go with my
wife and daughter and they teach me how
to be more flexible
[Music]
okay that's kind of funny
he makes me laugh
I remember really hating Michael Strahan
because I was like he he doesn't have a
good like broadcasting Voice or whatever
but honestly now I have to eat the [ __ ]
sandwich he's he's the perfect daytime
morning goofball because that's what you
need in the morning you're getting ready
for work you're having your coffee
feeding your dogs and [ __ ] you're all
cranky you just need something on in the
background what's fun and Rachel raised
me now that Regis is dead and he's not
screaming at you in the mornings you
need something because that was the guy
yeah every morning it got you very
excited
come on we gotta go to work make the
coffee and you're like all right Gelman
I miss Regis Regis
you're gonna shut up I love God damn it
your Regis impression is just you
yelling Gelman yeah
that is that's him that's right Calvin
you remember when we talked to him last
weekend
it's like remember when he used to do
one-arm push-ups to impress his guests
he was a mad man this was a Madman his
videos there's so many all videos online
in this day of people just approaching
him on the street like when he's off and
like he was always nice to everything he
was always Regis so be like that's right
good to see out here in New York City it
was just like I miss Regis man R.I.P man
you were a beast dude he was
[Applause]
it's not moving it's pretty he might
actually be able to move it imagine he
broke it it started running I still saw
I didn't know how strong I was really
sorry about that I did it the Goof it
was good there's no way I was going and
they forgive him because he's so nice he
does the old Simpsons penguin thing it's
my first day it's like the cops just go
no that's fine all our infrastructure is
like this now
I want to tell you you put a smile on
all of our faces the second you walk in
Good Morning Good Morning America oh
yeah
cuts to him in Israel and he's just like
arm in arm with like a Palestinian and
an Israeli and it is and he's just like
we are the world
Michael Strahan goes and accidentally
knocks down the Wailing Wall when he
goes to pray on it
I'm so sorry
so I'm gonna give this to somebody Robin
you take it
did you like the Minnie Mouse I got one
even bigger for you
oh man that's really sweet
that's actually really sweet yeah what's
up baby listen somebody told me you
turning you you turn in a certain age
Fox
because I kind of feel like Jamie Foxx
is up there right because I mean I
remember like Jamie Foxx was an adult
when we were children
he's 54. he's older than Michael's
damn
how don't crack yeah black smoke crack
I'm with you I mean they got money you
got money and if you're not living like
I don't think dirty riding dirty yeah I
don't think Jamie Foxx has been a guy
that's been known for now free basic
cocaine with hookers you got Bobby Brown
in it he wasn't Bobby Brown I don't
think him and Michael Strahan are
crushing packs and Newports and getting
drunk every night so I'm pretty sure
that's why they look they could probably
because it's the same like Jamie Foxx
has money he's got the same dudes the
Christian Bale has on [ __ ] speed dial
that's like hey man you know I'm
starting a little flat like I need to
fix this like Carly pastern come make my
food and Harley faster Nick shows up
that's what it is
hey Jamie you ever want to see your
[ __ ] kids again or be sure we'd be a
shame if everybody thought Jamie Foxx
was all sudden crazy
can you imagine 50 years with that Gap
and you never closed it no matter how
much money you make you still got your
Gap so you let them know I ain't
changing for nobody because I could
afford a business life I could afford
breakfast it's actually kind of funny
[ __ ] yeah but why would he like it's
iconic no that's a thing it would be
like Letterman getting it fixed you'd be
like the [ __ ] man or what's her face uh
the model with the mole
Cindy Crawford removing the mole at that
point I'm like no you're known for that
now
[Applause]
wait America you're about to be awake
[Music]
and over Stephanopoulos is just doing
this
and it's it's that classic like
Stephanopoulos just hates him because he
wants to be the cool liked guy of course
but even if Strahan wasn't there you
wouldn't be the cool lights guy yeah
you're the miserable old [ __ ]
journalistic hat exactly he's just the
one coming in singing and dancing
bringing cupcakes for people I stopped
on the way and I went to that cronuts
place I got everybody grown up and
you're like man how you know I like this
guy stop by Dunkin Donuts got a box of
joe for everybody you're like this guy
rules and that's Stephanopoulos this is
the guy it's in his office the whole
time until the show starts
what's this
what Eli
hey Michael happy 50th birthday pal when
I came to the Giants I knew you were old
I didn't know you were that old geez
you're ancient come on man oh I Don't
Wanna Die I'm afraid I'm afraid I don't
trust me
I don't trust me I know hey did you guys
hear Strahan's 50th birthday we did one
for every job he has I hear
that's a
okay that's a pretty good line he
doesn't everything
stepping up this is like I only have
hundreds
it's fine I don't need I'm just kidding
I don't care
this guy's just yelling this counts as a
present
this is your gift this is your gift
[Applause]
you know I heard you're 50. I'm gonna
slap the [ __ ] out of you if you say it
God damn [ __ ] you up